how much do you see your dad in you  that's gross  [Music]  how much do you think we're alike  an unfortunate amount if I gotta be  super honest  you and I have the same connotations the  way we talk we have the same mannerisms  we both say hey man yep  um I'll tell you what though I don't  talk like this  every time you talk about is yourself  yourself as a kid you never use the  voice but anytime you talk about  literally anybody else whether it's your  brothers whether it's me whether it's uh  my older brother use the voice why do  you take yourself out of that because  this is my voice no that's not how that  works you tell me I should do an  impersonation of myself is that what  you're saying yes I am I am doing one  right now  how am I doing I feel like I sound just  like me